hi hello my name is James James
where you from James I'm from Mayo
they're lovely I do live here there no I
live here all right fair enough
what'd you do here I'm an engineer
Oh Oh an aeronautical engineer an
aeronautical engineer he's clever
James has studied in the past exam well
judges well we're hope he'll be lying
yeah yeah man aeronautical engineer
thanks for asking
off you go with your story James okay so
a couple years ago I was going to a
family wedding and I was my family were
actually going there before me and I was
meeting up with him for the reception I
was really really late so they decided
to leave the key at reception for me I
got there got the key went up to the
room showered change dropped my bags
went down and joined the wedding and
when the way to get finished about three
o'clock in the morning I decided okay
it's time to go to bed went upstairs
Todd I quietly sneak into the room maybe
not wake everyone up opened the door
went in and the lights flipped on but it
wasn't my family who were in the room it
was three fully grown naked men and a
woman on the bed
good story so annoying is that is the
surprising you and do you know them
no I didn't know them so we got the
wedding ready to know but the most
Awkward part was I had to walk over to
my bike which was in the slowly packed
my bag and like backed out of the room
as they were shouting at me
oh listen she was probably out of a
break too bit
it's good though so nervous and she said
she banged on the door it come on
legging it was blank
aside from one sentence that she'd
written on it which was of the reasons
why you think he should be Teacher of
the Year and she'd written he's a well
good laugh and he don't make us do no
work